hi everyone welcome to the Khan Academy
daily homeroom livestream for those of
y'all who are wondering what this is
this is something that we started when
we started seeing the school closures
really around the world as a way to stay
connected and have interesting
conversations about things related to
the crisis education or just frankly
interesting conversation before we get
into today's conversation which will
promise to be interesting everything
that we're a lot right now I do want to
make a special shout out to several
corporations that stepped up we are not
for profit
we only district philanthropic donations
we're running at a deficit even before
the crisis and now our server costs have
gone up we're trying to accelerate a
bunch of programs to special thanks to
Bank of America Google org AT&T fastly
and Novartis for stepping up really in
record time and helping us close that
gap we do continue to run a deficit so
with any donation even a $3 or $5
donation those add up and that's what
allows Khan Academy to do what we do and
make it free and non-commercial and
accessible to students all over the
world and teachers and parents all over
the world so with that said I'm eager to
introduce our guest Angela Duckworth
Angela how are you I'm fine Sal how are
you I'm doing all right and Angela you
are you have the distinction of being
our first to repeat guest on the live
stream I'm so excited I hope I don't
blow it be based on something that's we
don't just do that willy-nilly okay it
is a compliment so so for those of y'all
who did not see the first episode with
Angela a few weeks ago Angela is really
one of the world leaders on talking
about mindset and particular
and how grit relates to things like
resilience and growth mindset and so you
could imagine in this kovat socially
distant world we're all living in where
we're trying to figure out how to keep
people motivated how do we keep learning
and and that's how do we deal with
everything going on with our lives
Angela is a really interesting person to
talk with and we have a bunch of
questions already from our last session
that I hope to get to some of them but
for any of y'all on Facebook or YouTube
feel free to add
questions and we have team members at
Khan Academy who are going to be
surfacing them to myself and Angela but
Angela may be a good place to start you
know last time we talked a lot about
growth mindset and grit and it's kind of
this you know you can easily get into
this view that like look if you have a
growth mindset you fail you hit some
adversity you just keep chipping away at
it and eventually you'll get to the
other side but how does that equate with
the other notion that you know not
everyone has the same starting point not
everyone has the same tools at their
disposal so how do you how do you you
know there's growth mindset and grit and
resilience and then there's equity
really yeah I have lately been not just
lately I have been reading criticism of
my work and also Carol Dweck's work on
on growth mindset and when I get past
the natural human reaction which is
total defensiveness and I really listen
I hear something that's really valuable
and I think the critiques are that if
you talk about grit resilience and
growth mindset and character it sounds
like it's all about the kid it's all
about the student and the entire burden
and responsibility falls on their
shoulders and there's no mention of
equity and poverty lack of opportunity
you know massive differences that we're
all well aware exist not only in our
country but around the world and I think
the reconciliation is this it is not
that these you know ideas about mindset
and learning and grit are I think at
odds with you know it's not an either-or
like it's either the situation or it's
the person it's both and and you know
very briefly I'll just say Sal that in
psychology there was like a war between
people in psychology psychological
researchers who thought that you know so
much of our behavior was about our
personality and who we were then there
were the other psychologists who said no
it's really about the situation and the
war is over because really everyone
recognizes that they both matter I was
once in a classroom in a public school
that shall remain nameless but these two
boys were sitting at their desks all the
other kids were doing their work they
were all on these laptops you know
pounding with some assigned activity
these two kids are doing nothing now
you walked in just at that moment you
would say well those two kids don't have
grit those two kids are doing nothing
but I walked in actually before the bell
rang and I saw all the students walk up
to the laptop cart and these two boys
were last in line and they got the two
broken laptops they couldn't do anything
all period because they lacked
opportunity and I think that's the
mistake that I fear critics not wanting
to make not to mistake lack of
opportunity for lack of grit and I you
know have to say that I completely agree
with that that's power plan and your
example is a good one if you got the
broken laptop I'm that's an extreme
example of course you're not going to be
able to even apply your grit or your
growth mindset and it is fascinating how
in many times in academic circles people
can get into these religious camps but
it's clearly not one or the other to
your point that environment and
opportunity for sure' is going to make a
difference but whatever set of cards you
are dealt if you are able to approach
that with a growth mindset given that
context you're going to get further all
else equal that's not to say that if two
kids don't get to a certain place or the
same place that you can somehow blame
the kid who didn't get there on their
lack of mindset it might have been other
things it might have been a context so
yeah it makes makes all the sense in the
world to me on that I mean you know just
double-clicking on that a little bit you
know this question from Facebook Ritchie
get get ler asks I think a lot of
parents are wondering this for at least
one of their children how do you help
inspire a kid who wants to practice to
want to practice something is it
essential that we simply do things we
like to do in order to be successful and
we touched all about that a little bit
in our last conversation but yeah how do
you motivate someone to practice maybe
something that it's not obvious that
they love it or do you just say well
only do the things that you you love or
argue how can you learn to love things
you know since our last conversation
which is now a few weeks ago so I've
been thinking about what you said in in
that part of the conversation which as
you said that pretty much anything can
become fascinating to you and when you
need to record a video you like you
don't record until you can become
fascinated but but gosh what
what couldn't you know what would fall
outside of that category and I've been
thinking about it because I I wonder
whether for you as like that who you
aren't your core as a teacher and so
what excites you is being able to
understand something and then being able
to teach it and communicate it you can
certainly tell me but let me respond
first to that question directly I think
that when kids are starting out in
something that the the thing to
emphasize is interest and enjoyment and
to wait a little bit if you can to
impose you know the hardest most
challenging repetitive kind of practice
and that is because until a child gets
engaged in something it's a it's a very
romantic period in fact some scientists
use the term the Romantic period to
describe that inertial kind of
flirtation like you you you kind of have
a joy to what you're doing and then you
love it so much that you you can evolve
into somebody who's willing to do more
drills more like really hard stuff now
with school something so that you have
much more experience with them I do you
might say that you know for math for
example something I know that you know
where Khan Academy are all started it's
it's it's not necessarily like if you
think yourself like well what is this
romantic are you gonna come because you
know my kid really doesn't love it I I
think that even if you could just take
it as a principle right like how much
enjoyment and interest and fun can there
be maybe it won't be as fun as you know
minecraft but like the more the better
and the earlier you are in your
development as a learner the more you
really need that I think yeah the way I
think oh you are right I realized that
my mindset toward certain things maybe
is it as mainstream as as as we would
like that we would all you know I I can
get excited about almost anything oh
this weekend
you know I'm swiffering it we you know
wet swiffering the house and I'm
fascinated by it yeah I love it I love
it so you know I do try to convince
myself that if there's something I'm
gonna do I might as well enjoy it I
might as well appreciate what I'm going
to get out of it and you know a good
example
you know kids for the
part don't complain if they're working
out at the gym and they got a run on a
treadmill for 30 minutes or you know
they're trying to weight lift and
they're doing these really weird
exercises that work on their forearms or
or something like that because they know
that it's all well first of all this
often times we'll enjoy because they're
like hey I'm working on something I'm
building a habit that's going to make me
better in some way more prepared for
battle with the world or understand the
world or be able to engage with the
world in a stronger way so that's my gut
sense is that the more people just
appreciate that the more that even some
of the you know little hairy things that
you have to deal with in academics you
can kind of power through them because
you're like oh this is gonna make me
better at at being a holistic person you
know my my son is you know takes piano
lessons and he loves playing piano and
famously when you play piano you have to
practice your scales and scales in a
vacuum you know just just going up and
down that that that's obviously not
composing you're obviously not gonna
make friends at a party by just playing
your scales it might not be particularly
that fun but when you recognize that by
building that muscle memory and getting
better and better at your scales and
even professional pianists practice
their scales it the scales actually kind
of become fun and become interesting and
you know you get you're becoming better
every time you do them yeah and I think
you're reminding us sell that you know
what's interesting in fun isn't just
objectively what the activity is there
are piano teachers I specifically know
of one named Cindy Lam in Pasadena
California who makes scales fun
she makes games out of them her students
actually enjoy doing scales so it's not
just like is it enjoyable or not
enjoyable but it's in a way like how its
framed you know one thing that makes
things really boring for kids is when we
don't give them a purpose or a point to
it like do this worksheet do this why
just do it you're not giving the student
any reason to feel like this activities
connected to any larger goal and
actually there is a science of boredom
and one of the ways things can be bored
and boring is because it lacks any any
obvious purpose another and I actually
just wrote about this and I actually um
mention khanacademy specifically as an
antidote to this so one other way to be
bored so I just said one way to be bored
is like what's the point of this another
way to be bored if things are too easy
or too hard and either of those create
the psychology of boredom and the reason
I mentioned Khan Academy in this little
essays because I think this is why among
other reasons Khan Academy is so great
because it allows students to self kind
of calibrate and also through your
back-end algorithms to deliver to
students like what they need in their
sweet spot but anyway as parents and as
educators I think the principle is you
know can you make things more enjoyable
and interesting can you you know give
kids the bigger picture like this is why
we're doing these push-ups so this is
why we're doing scales and also can you
calibrate so the things are neither too
easy nor too hard yeah and I have to
remind myself that all the time I mean
especially with I've talked about this
livestream our older to my 11 year old
an 8 year old have for the most part
have been quite good in this socially
distanced remote learning whatever you
want to call it world they've been but
our five-year-old has been difficult and
it's very easy to fall into that
frustrated Parent Trap of like look you
just need to do this one worksheet you
said to do this one exercise and it you
know but they kind of get entrenched
because and then if you just and then
look and then you both escalate at some
point you're like giving them a timeout
is they're they're screaming at you or
they you know and and I've had to learn
some often times the hard way you said
to sometimes take a step back and say ok
how do I put this into context that in
this case my youngest my son will have
fun like when we turn this into a game
does it not even a five-year-old will
rebel if they feel like they're being
forced or coerced versus if they are
invested in the project and even if they
don't see you know they you know it's
hard to convince a five-year-old that
like hey by writing better you know
you're going to have this ability to
communicate in the world and you're
going to do that the rest of your life
but even even just to say you know it's
building a muscle it's fun it's a game I
think I think is a start
so one thing I forgot to introduce you
but people saw you on your title on on
the
Green is that you have started something
called the character lab and many people
here have asked about it from YouTube
Sean number what does character lab
James Liu question for Angela a bit
about resources in character lab arcade
Jack what is character lab so people
want to know Angela what is character
lab thank you for those three questions
because I'm so in love with character
lab it's a nonprofit I started with two
educators and its mission is to advance
scientific insights that help kids
thrive now character is a word that
Aristotle and Maria Montessori and
Martin Luther King used but I think
commonly it's called social-emotional
learning or 21st century skills call
whatever you want the list is the list
that all parents and educators want kids
to develop gratitude and curiosity
empathy social intelligence grit growth
mindset there's a science behind any of
those things that I mentioned and I
think the idea that we're living in
exciting time said rather than just
sermonizing to our kids about these
things that we hope they'll develop we
can actually draw on random assignments
that you know show how to improve growth
mindset and ditto for gratitude etc so
so if you go to that website it's all
like Khan Academy philanthropically
supported so if you are parent or an
educator in particular I hope that you
find you know direct dialing scientists
through this website as it were because
every word on that website is written by
a scientist not by an intermediary and I
highly recommended we've used the work
at Carey lab I look at it sometimes the
reference myself for his family and you
know we have a lab school we started and
we've leveraged a lot of the work at
character lab to think about because one
of the things we try to do at the lab
school is not just kids are developing
academically but social emotional
development is a very explicit part and
we've used a lot of the taxonomies and
frameworks from the character lab to
think about how do we even you know what
dimensions matter and how do we even
measure or think about measuring some of
these things so from YouTube we have a
teacher here Danielle Kendra's asks how
can teachers encourage grit during
remote learn
with students out of reach it seems
easier than ever for students to give up
ah this is a this is a question is near
and dear to my heart I have an 18 year
old in the seventh year on hold at home
little a little bit farther down the
track than you so in terms of how my
kids are but you know when there's not
only distance learning but there's also
this like very blurry line between
morning afternoon and evening between
weekday and weekend it's just very easy
for like suddenly like nine days to slip
away and like nothing really got done so
it's a it's a terrific question
I think the person that I've turned to
the most during this distance learning
period for wisdom is Ron Berger and Sal
you know the expeditionary learning
schools and and and Ron in particular as
the chief academic officer is such a
sage on these things
and I think what his advice would be is
to actually take the opportunity of
distance learning and this you know
enforced strangeness that we have as
educators and and use it to move more
aggressively toward project-based
learning towards toward things were like
you know it's not just like do this
worksheet or fill out this thing it's
like we have a project like we're gonna
try to figure out you know how to you
know make like recycling work in this
neighborhood or you could do something
that's very covert specific like there
are lots of you know older people in our
neighborhood how can we take on as a
project like getting them their
groceries now some of the stuff you're
thinking like how does this have to you
know what does it have to do with like
reading writing and arithmetic and I
think there it's not easy to like always
draw the line but that's the challenge
in other words when you do projects that
are authentic you do have to do a little
more work as an educator to think how
you're going to integrate some of the
basic skills that we need students to
learn but the tilt I think is really
powerful because when you do have a
project that you're excited about
you're not like dragging yourself out of
bed to force yourself to do it you're
excited to do it and you're kind of
thinking about it frankly like all the
time so to learn more I think if you
google expeditionary learning and Ron
Berger you'll find that he's writing a
lot of wise things right now
and you bring up an interesting point
you we talked about these
camps these dogmatic camps that
sometimes form in academic circles
before we were talking about you know is
it about context and equity or is it
more about mindset and to your point
it's not either/or it's both matter and
you know I've seen a similar because
you're talking about project-based
learning I've seen a similar type of
dogmatic battle in education circles
where there's I guess you could say the
traditionalists who would say no you've
got to learn those skills you got to
learn you know practice your scales so
to speak before you become a great
pianist and then you would have the more
you could say progressive educators
project-based oriented program who are
like no you should start composing on
day one so it becomes interesting but
what I I heard you say is it still is a
bit of a both you shouldn't you
shouldn't it
you shouldn't go you shouldn't it's not
all or nothing on one side or the other
yeah absolutely you know both the head
is pretty much the answer to so many
questions and I think that is because
there are trade-offs right and and in
project-based learning you get certain
advantages but you know maybe you don't
get the you know super you know
densely-packed like you know repetitive
skill part right but but then when you
just do that then you maybe lose a
little bit of the intrinsic motivation
and the purpose and we're just talking
about how that can be really
demotivating so I think with
project-based learning and maybe more
traditional instruction I mean I'm not
I'm not an expert or veteran educator
but it does seem to me that they are
complementary and when you see the the
best schools and the best classrooms and
frankly like you know just the best
learning environments more generally
there tends to be both rigor and
autonomy there append to be you know
both creative projects and like a
systematic approach and and this is
again why it's not easy to do but I do
think it's what we're we're all aiming
for yeah completely agree you know I'm
just using a sports analogy if you're a
football player you obviously have to
practice playing football like you have
to play in games like that are real
games and that's kind of the projects
but you'll also do sprints and
weightlifting and you know drills
catching or throwing a but you know you
know just different random exercises
that feel a little bit and you'll
perfect those exercises but once again
if you just did that you'd be like
what's the point but
you know that hey this is making me more
prepared for a game and I may or may not
use some of these skills in a given game
but it's useful tool kit for the rest of
my life then all of a sudden that too
can be motivating and that's what I tell
kids I was like look you know I'm not
sure whether you're going to have to use
this method for factoring a quadratic at
some point in the next five years I am
genuinely not sure but I am sure that
understanding this is going to be you
can build on it so that you can learn
things like statistics you can learn
things like trigonometry and I can't
tell you how many areas I mean
statistics you talk about a project
almost any project if you want to do it
legitimately at a kind of a impact the
world level statistics it's going to be
a piece of that you know almost anything
that you're making designing creating
trigonometry geometry and some basic
level of algebra is going to be a part
of it anything you do in this world
being able to have reasonable reading
comprehension and writing capability is
going to be kind of table stakes in this
world so it's good to make sure that you
don't have that one spelling error that
you know is just like what is you know
to sound
literate which I'm guilty of sometimes I
always blame it on typos but right now
like having that conversation in a in a
like you know sometimes people ask me
like well how old your kids need to be
before you can talk to them at a level
of sophistication about you know some of
these you know issues like the the
metacognition is it to beyond them to
like you know really understand why
they're doing this thing why are my and
I'm like it's pretty much never too
young
honestly like just start I mean you know
kids are smarter than you so though you
know don't use jargon and they don't
understand try to explain it another way
but I think you know one of the big
changes in education I wonder if you
agree cell is well I hope it's a change
in education is that you know we're I'm
not saying that like the student and the
teacher are interchangeable and there's
no reason why we even have to I'm not
saying that just saying that students
are remarkably perceptive and
intelligent and they can understand when
you say like this is why we're doing
this like the you know the scope and
sequence looks like this and like we
have to get through this part so you can
get to this part if you don't get this
part you know so so I think they're not
too young to understand any of those
things and and we should never assume
that they're too young to understand
those things we should always at least
try to communicate to them like the why
of what they're doing I agree 100% I
think it's so easy for us to assume our
five six seven eight year olds you know
that they don't think about how the
world works but they do and if you talk
to him about jobs and the competitive
workplace and and how and what skills
you need to be able to participate it's
funny I think that was this was many
years ago like five or six years ago I
got an email from a mother and she had a
picture of her child and he was working
like dill Jeannie was a seven year old I
felt bit so there's some interview like
this where I was talking about the
future of work and that you could you
know the future of work is going to be
defined by your ability to keep learning
that you're not just going to have a set
of skills that you can apply until you
get your pension that automation and and
even some you know it's gonna make labor
artificial intelligence robotics so you
want to be able to participate at the
top of that pyramid in the knowledge
economy and get many as many people
there and so this this this a mother I
guess awe that interview with her
seven-year-old son and then immediately
after that interview he went to his room
and like she didn't like see him for
another hour and like she went in the
room for well she's what are you doing
he's like I'm to working on Khan Academy
and he's he she's like why he's like I
need to make sure I don't get
economically marginalized I think you
use words like almost economically
marginalized it's clearly a precocious
kid using words like that at age seven
but he said something that felt like I
want to make sure that I don't get like
you know automated out of the economy so
he definitely understood and that that's
kind of that I remember there's you know
I'm dating myself I'm you know there's a
Karl Malone quote famous basketball
player for the Utah Jazz and he used to
imagine he used to say whenever I get
whenever I get tired I imagine that my
competitors are at the gym and I don't
want that to be like you know to stress
people out that you have to always be
like on top of it but that can also be a
little bit of a motivator that like you
know look it's you don't want your kids
to get stressed out but you also don't
want them to live in a reality where
they think that you know actually I see
this know the fight I grew up not so
wealthy so I had a little bit of a fire
in my belly because you know I could say
look I want a different stand
oh yeah you know I'm oh no my mom you
know we were she raised us by ourselves
and she was a cashier at some
convenience stores and you know so she
was the year I went to apply to college
she was making sixteen thousand a year
but that you know for me that created
kind of a little bit of a fire in my
belly you know I would see friends whose
parents were doctors and engineers and
lawyers I was like that's a good life
they're living in a nice house they are
able to go on vacations they go to
restaurants they don't reuse paper
towels like that's the life I want
I still reuse paper towels every now and
then but that's the life I want but you
know you oftentimes worry about I think
kids who grow up middle class or even
upper-middle class because like all my
parents did this it's must be kind of
easy this is just the way it is but then
they oh they later get a bit of a rude
awakening that know the world sometimes
can be a pretty you know these jobs just
don't fall in your lap that you you need
to prepare for them and there there are
kids with that fire in their belly who
are preparing for it from a very young
age because they you know they see the
reason at an early age they say wow if I
if I stay on track with my studies and
graduate from high school and do well in
college I can live over there and I can
go on vacations and I can support my
family and if I don't I might be living
under financial stress for a very very
very long time and you know - you're
only putting about equity it's not like
it's just all about the kids mindset it
for sure is a lot about support you know
even though I didn't grow up
particularly that that well off I had a
lot of support you know I had supports
from teachers who believed in me and who
took extra attention with me I had I was
exposed to people who did make it that
way so I was able to even see that side
of the world but yeah it's it's it is it
is fascinating how we can kind of keep
that keep that motivation by letting
people know a little bit about the
realities of world but without them
getting too stressed about it yeah
absolutely and you know use your
judgement but I I think one of the three
lines of what you're saying and what I
agree with is that you know kids don't
need to be like sheltered from like
my dad who was not so great at you know
thinking about how to talk to kids he
like just talked to me like I was an
adult and that wasn't always great but
it mostly was right so you know I
learned about supply and demand and I
learned about his particular view of the
economy and I learned about
thermodynamics and anyway I think kids
are so much smarter and so much more
ready than we often give them credit for
and if we try we can have conversations
with them about you know what it means
to be marginalized to the target
knowledge economy and maybe we can find
words that are like a little more
intuitive for them but it doesn't mean
we shouldn't try to have those
conversations I think I'm a little bit
like your dad I'm guilty of actually all
my kids like all of all of the lullabies
I sing to them are like classic rock
songs that I happen to the lyrics for so
like my kids like my their nighttime
lullaby like I said just last night for
you know azad who's five and a half year
old we say I sing Hotel California with
he's like what does it mean that her
mind is tiffany-twisted what's our
Mercedes Benz what scaliness
why does it have a warm smell the Hotel
California then maybe maybe I could
listen in because like I you can you can
check out anytime you like but you can
just can never leave that's a lot of
complication my kids what does it mean
to check out but not to leave good well
do you ever get to a really succinct you
know explanation like an unpacking of
the Hotel California I would appreciate
that because there's a few times I have
to kind of you know my five reels like
why do they stab it with their steely
knives and what beast are they trying to
kill and I'm let's not let's not go
there right now
aren't you asleep okay so so here's a
good question from Facebook Stephen
Cottrell before people start getting on
my horrible parenting habits so from
Stephen Cantrell what are tips on
developing a sense of purpose among
teenagers great question you know one of
the like like less known but I think
really important facts about adolescents
is that
you know teenagers are maybe more
purpose-driven
during that period of life then than any
other time and so we have a stereotype
of teenagers being selfish and even
narcissistic and and really to the
contrary they're extremely motivated by
fairness by equity by social change I
witnessed this myself with my own 17 and
18 year old I often get like mini
lectures on how I have to I think like I
think of myself as someone who's like
reasonably feminist and like they they
update me and correct me when they think
that that's needed so so then the
question is like how do we channel all
that adolescent you know purpose driven
motivation and I think one real
challenge this particular summer is that
a lot of things that I would typically
suggest like volunteer for this or you
know do that or you know those are for
clothes so it's gonna take a little more
creativity and proactivity the summer to
channel purpose appropriately for
teenagers one thing that I just heard of
is that there are and I'll send you the
links um so you know it's not it's not
perfect but but honestly I think it's
still great ways for teenagers to tutor
younger kids all throughout the summer
as you well know so what what the
pandemic has done is not only shine the
light on lack of equity but also
increased lack of equity and I think
there are a lot of people including you
and me who are terrified at the learning
losses particularly for less advantaged
kids so if you've got a purpose-driven
teenager in the house I'll send some
links over for ways that they could plug
in as as tutors and and one of the
silver linings is like it doesn't matter
where you live like you can find a kid
who's in your timezone and and you know
a starfish theory right like prevent at
least one child from falling behind this
year yeah I'll just doubly underline
what you just said you know for any
teenager or any young or any person who
says you know what do I do with myself
right now there's never been at least in
our lifetimes a bigger opportunity where
I've even a very young person from their
bedroom could actually do a lot of good
in the world to your point you could
tutor other people you know you could
start a new organization that connects
with maybe elderly who are living by
themselves or just people who are living
by themselves
helps with mental health issues and all
of these things are set up to be able to
do remotely and if you need to get out
of the house you know getting groceries
for folks especially elderly being able
to do services for them you know help
with their gardens you know what you can
any teenager any young person out there
if you brainstorm for half an hour
you're going to think of 30 really
fascinating ways that you could really
support a lot of folks right now so
guess who are like writing their cell
phone number on a piece of paper and
then just like shoving it in male slots
right and by the way as you might
imagine like not all the elderly are
heavily into texting or you know any
other so just like saying call me call
me this is where I live I would love to
like pick up groceries or go to the
pharmacy for you yeah like you said so
like when you just sit down and start to
make a list like you know you realize
that there's so much to do and I think
actually that's when teenagers are
happiest when they're being useful and
and and it's again an antidote to the
kind of despair that I think a lot of
teenagers are feeling like you know an
aimlessness like oh all these things are
taken from me but when you start going
out and spending most of your day
helping other people like all of that
basically evaporates yeah I think
there's another theme here which is you
know there's this thing like teenage
angst and they're in rebellion and my
belief is that that comes from the fact
that they are proto adults that in most
of human history they actually would be
kind of on the hunting parties they
would be helping out with all of the
different things that the village has to
take care of and the cooking the
cleaning the teaching the hunting the
fighting whatever it might be but in our
modern society would do it in a multiple
multiple age groups you know they would
be with the uncles and their cousins and
their aunts and but now we group them
into these very you know fairly narrow
age bands and they only we tell them to
only watch yeah your GPA your scores
your college admissions your
extracurriculars that's exactly we're
gonna rank or do far I mean for most of
human history actually what he said
people people kids included ran around
in multi h packs the five-year-olds or
at the seven year olds the seven year
olds with the 12 year olds and
by the way when you see kids were 5 7
and 12 you spontaneously see or you see
spontaneous like collaboration right 12
year olds take care of seven-year-old 7
year olds take care of 5 year olds now
we're in this really weird era where
we're like let's take a thousand 15 year
olds and put them together so they spent
all their time and then we're gonna rank
order them right so you're just
computing they have no tangible
responsibility other than these abstract
like I believe you have to learn all the
stuff obviously I'm a big believer you
got to learn your biology or chemistry
your writing you're reading your math
but but it's all abstract and it's all
about their own performance in it
it isn't about a collective it isn't
about making it and to your point they
are the most idealistic I mean you know
part of the reason you know a lot of
soldiers and things are on the younger
side obviously your body is very
physically able there but these are some
of the more idealistic people and you
know in history sometimes people have
taken not so great advantage of that but
they believe that change can happen and
they want the adventures in the world
they don't want to just kind of fall
into the day-to-day grind and so yeah
100 hundred hundred percent agree with
you
Wow whenever I week at Angela the time
goes by very very fast so maybe maybe
maybe yeah yeah do you have time for one
more I have time for one more yes okay
sounds good
let's see let me find a good one those
are all great so this is our this is a
we have a see there's a couple of
questions here you know Carl group these
together Carly angstrom what do you
think is the best way to teach kids to
break down their own large tasks and by
extension all of us to break down or
talk of a big problem you want to solve
loneliness how do you saw our earlier
point you know from YouTube Audrey Oh
Mary are there any strategies that you
recommend for staying on task to be
productive and then Brielle Lee asks how
can you connect the lack of motivation
towards online learning with staying at
home I've noticed that many struggled to
stay on task so you had just any parting
thoughts on how do you break things down
stay motivated stay on task stay focused
so I'll just give one suggestion and
that is this in
wishing that you have that a big thing
needs to be broken up into small things
is exactly right and there was research
actually not very far away from where
Sal Khan lives by Al bandura at Stanford
now many years ago where he actually had
elementary school kids who are learning
math and in one condition they had to
learn a lot of math and in another
condition he all he did was he helped
break down the math the same math into
sub-goals into smaller parts and there
was a dramatic benefit and those kids
did better and they think the life
lesson as you say Sal not only for kids
but for us is that when you have big
things you break him into small things
and when you take those small things and
you break a mutant further that's when I
think you really get momentum and I'll
just give one personal example the
hardest thing I ever did professionally
was to write my book and when I thought
about like writing a book it was like
too big then I thought like well I'll
just work on chapter one still too big
and I thought like well just work on
like the first half of chapter one still
too big and I found myself
procrastinating and just never feeling
like I wanted to get started then
finally I worked down the small things
like today I'm going to write a sentence
maybe uh and and what I meant by maybe
is it like I might throw out that
sentence now I had broken down the big
thing a book into smaller things a
chapter into smaller swine so that the
thing that I had to do that day was tiny
and actually I think that was a great
strategy because once I wrote that
sentence I was like well since I'm
sitting here I may as well write another
one and in general I think if we can
help kids learn the skill of breaking
down the big into small and getting
started then will be actually a long way
towards helping them finish what they
begin yeah couldn't agree more
you know I that's that's a lot of my
narrative too if you know just so these
tasks that you can take half an hour
hour chip away at them but then you look
back on you're like oh there was a lot
it's better than nothing which is
basically what happens when you
procrastinate is that when you're doing
right just just get moving just get
moving
so Angela thank you so much I mean they
continue to be so many great questions
coming in but yeah thank you for all the
research you have done
helping us think about how we can
ourselves have more grit and and how we
can think about working with our
children to get that going thank you so
I so enjoyed this conversation likewise
so thank you everyone for joining as
always Angela Duckworth has you know
both informative and entertaining and
always a pleasure to chat with about
about all topics we have several other
really interesting folks coming on we're
gonna have Tom Friedman later this week
just talking about the world in this
kovat world well we're going to have Stu
shmall from MIT admissions to talk about
how our college admissions or even the
nature of college may be changing
because of this crisis and and we have
many many more guests over the next
couple of weeks so look forward to
seeing y'all and and don't forget we are
not-for-profit if you're in a position
to do so please think about making a
donation to Khan Academy thanks everyone
you